er ist die Antwort auf 16 Jahre Angela
Merkel 16 Jahre macht mit der Teile der
machtpartei CDU gefremdelt haben ein
historisches Kuriosum kann es also
Friedrich Schmerz besser die Antwort
steht aus dafür macht einer aus den
eigenen Reihen richtig Ärger zwischen
Maaßen und Mittel ein Jahr CDU-Chef
Friedrich Merz jetzt in der Phönix Runde
Phoenix Runde
herzlich Willkommen bei uns meine Gäste
Jana Schimke ist bei uns
CDU-Bundestagsabgeordnete aus
Brandenburg und stellvertretende
Bundesvorsitzende der Wirtschafts- und
mittelstandsunion von CDU und CSU
abgekürzt m it mit Gewitter ist
Landesvorsitzende der Jungen Union in
Bremen jüngst es Mitglied im CDU
Bundesvorstand also der Parteiführung
und Mitgründerin der
klimaunion Ausbau der politischen
Inhalte der Union Sachen Klimaschutz und
die kandidieren bei der Wahl zur
Bremischen Bürgerschaft im Mai als
co-spitzenkandidatin für ihre Partei für
die CDU Sabine am Orte ist
innenpolitische Korrespondentin der taz
und sie sind dort unter anderem
zuständig für die Berichterstattung über
die Unionsparteien schließlich Albrecht
von Lucke Publizist und Redakteur der
politischen Monatszeitschrift Blätter
und Deutsch für deutsche und
internationale Politik bevor wir hier
richtig loslegen Liebe ZuschauerInnen
liebe Zuschauer Georg Maaßen der
ehemalige Präsident der des Bundesamtes
für Verfassungsschutz und Vorsitzender
werteunion der hat die CDU ja
aufgebracht mit seinen heftig
umstrittenen höchst Umständen Äußerungen
zu Rassenlehre und zu
Verschwörungstheorien und er hat sich
heute in der phoenix-sendung der Tag
geäußert zu dem angedrohten Rauswurf aus
der CDU
bisher weiß ich nur aus den Medien dass
man gerne möchte dass ich bis Sonntag 12
Uhr eine Erklärung abgebe ich war vorher
noch mal bei meinem Postfach bis jetzt
habe ich noch keinen Schreiben der CDU
bekommen das ist das Mindeste was ich
eigentlich erwarten kann dass man mich
persönlich oder schriftlich durch ein
Schriftsatz darüber informiert was man
gerne von mir möchte wenn ich es bekomme
wenn ich prüfen und mich dann
gegebenenfalls äußern das wird in jedem
Fall ein blauer Brief aus dem Konrad
adenauerhaus sein mit der dringenden
Aufforderung bis Sonntag die Partei zu
verlassen Frau Schimke das Maß ist voll
in Bezug auf Hans-Georg Maaßen sagt auch
ihr parteiche Friedrich Merz und will
ihn aus der Partei werfen es gibt einen
Beschluss des Bundesvorstandes sind sie
auch ebenfalls der Meinung dass oder
sind sie auch für den Ausschluss falls
ähmaßen bis Sonntag nicht die Partei
verlässt nun ja also man muss das schon
prüfen und wenn ein Ausschlussverfahren
so einfach zu machen wäre dann bräuchte
man erfahren und insofern sagt mir doch
zumindest meine politische Erfahrung
dass man die Prüfung dieses Verfahrens
abzuwarten hat ich möchte mich da zum
heutigen Zeitpunkt nicht so sehr aus dem
Fenster lehnen Frau Winter
Friedrich Merz haben Sie das Gefühl oder
die Vermutung dass er jetzt gerade in
der causa-maßen besonders konsequent
sein will nachdem seine Aussagen zu den
kleinen Paschas also Kindern aus
Migranten Familien in der Schule auch in
der eigenen Partei bei manchen zu
stürmen rund hin geführt hat also zu
allerersten sind das zwei komplett
unterschiedliche Sachverhalte Friedrich
Merz hat sich sehr klar und sehr richtig
aus meiner Sicht in der kausalmaßen
geäußert hat gesagt das Maß ist voll für
jemanden wie ihn ist aus unserer Sicht
kein Platz in dieser Partei und deswegen
finde ich es auch richtig dass wir jetzt
ein Parteiausschlussverfahren anstreben
sollte Herr Maaßen sich nicht dazu
entscheiden die verteilt zu verlassen
das heißt aber diese Äußerung das ist
jetzt auch vor dem nicht vor dem
Hintergrund zu sehen dass er ja durch
die Äußerung über die kleinen Paschas
auch in der Partei ich habe ja gesagt
stirnranzen bei manchen verursacht hat
man kann sicherlich über die Wortwahl
streiten die ja da benutzt hat aber er
spricht ein wichtiges Thema an gelungene
Migration und ich würde mir auch
wünschen wenn man sich die gesamte
Sendung anschaut bei Markus Lanz und das
habe ich getan Wunder viele kluge Sachen
gesagt ich hätte vielleicht auch ein
anderes Wort benutzt in diesem Moment
dennoch weißt er ja auf ein Problem hin
was besteht und zwar dass wir
unterschiedliche Werte in
unterschiedlichen Kulturen vielleicht
auch erleben und wir natürlich ein
Problem haben auch an manchen Stellen
was Integration angeht hat man ja nicht
zum Schluss jetzt auch Silvester hier in
Berlin gesehen diese Äußerung wäre
seinem unmittelbaren Vorgänger oder auch
den beiden Vorgängerinnen und so nicht
über die Lippen gekommen mit den kleinen
Paschas ist das ähm ein Indiz für eine
konservative Wende der CDU oder ist das
kaffeeserei nein das ist es in mancher
Hinsicht unbedingt Friedrich Merz hat
selber ganz klar gesagt er will das ist
ganz entscheidend die AFD um die Hälfte
reduzieren und in zweierlei Hinsicht
macht er das und ich glaube in
fatalerweise er macht es in einer im
sprachjung viele mittelwähler der CDU
verprellenweise das war ja davor mit dem
Begriff sozialtourismus ähnlich fatal er
musste ihn sogar zurücknehmen was zeigt
dass ein erheblicher Teil der Partei
nicht diese wortwahlkutiert die kleinen
Paschas gehen in die gleiche Richtung
ich glaube sogar dass er mit einer
anderen Intonation und nicht in der Art
und Weise wie der originäre Friedrich
merze der landsinnung wieder zum
Ausdruck kam mit einer hohen
Emotionalität wenn er es geschickter
gemacht hätte hätten viele ihm das
Problem tatsächlich abgenommen und als
ein wahres erkannt aber so hat er
natürlich genau wieder den backlash der
Mitte Fraktion erlebt und jetzt kommt
das ganz große Problem mit Herrn Maße
heute ist für meinen verstorben
schwarzer Tag für die CDU und auch
persönlich für März hätte viel früher
und das hätte es plausibel gemacht einen
geraden Strich ziehen müssen gegen
werteunion es ist ja kein Einzel was
Maßen hier auftritt es gibt davor ein
max Orte der vor einem Jahr für die AFD
als bundespräsidentenkandidat angetreten
ist und Herr Merz persönlich hat im
Wahlkampf 2021 in Richtung damals noch
Armin Laschet gesagt mit mir wird eine
klare Kante gegen die AFD gezogen er
hätte damals hätte damals vor einem Jahr
gegen Max Otte bereits
gesagt wir machen ein
unvereinbarkeitsbeschluss gegenüber der
werteunion die längst nicht mehr
Fahrwasser der Union ist sondern längst
im Fahrwasser der AFD hätten wir all
diese Probleme heute nicht da hat er
fundamental versagt und ich glaube es
ist ganz entscheidend dass die Union
hier klar zieht was noch
christianokratisches und rechts
ansprechen dieses Thema vom Orte im
Migration Klima Sozialpolitik versuchte
ich März da die verschiedenen Strömungen
der Partei auch auszutarieren ähm
dass die es in der Partei ja auch gibt
die Union die CDU möchte ja
Volkspartei bleiben und schnell
eigentlich wieder Kanzlerpartei werden
ich finde das ist noch nicht so richtig
absehbar weil ein ganz klarer Kurs von
Herrn Merz eigentlich noch nicht zu
erkennen ist also ich würde Albrecht von
Lucke da recht geben dass das mit der
werteunion und auch Herrn Maaßen viel zu
spät passiert ist eigentlich hätte der
nach den Äußerungen die er in der
Vergangenheit getätigt hat gar nicht
mehr zur Bundestagswahl antreten dürfen
das ging jetzt nicht auf Konto von Herrn
März sondern das war noch Herr Laschet
aber die haben sich so ein bisschen
gescheute eine klare Kante zu ziehen
weil ich glaube alle Angst haben dass
sie sich da mit der Basis in Thüringen
verstärken Beispiel nicht genannt habe
Klima und Sozialpolitik versucht er
darin Ausgleich zu finden naja er hat es
gab ja jetzt diese Tage in Weimar vom
Bundesvorstand wo es um Klima und
Wirtschaftspolitik geht von daher
probiert es schon dieses Thema zu setzen
das ist natürlich auch dringend
notwendig weil die kompetenzwerte der
CDU sind da absolut miserabel und wenn
er
größere Gruppen wieder gewinnen will in
der Mitte auch die Jugend dann muss er
dieses Thema besetzen Sozialpolitik ist
unterbelichtet würde ich sagen
differenzieren der Parteivorsitzende hat
ja in der Bild am Sonntag gesagt der
Kurs der Union sich klar nach
Rechtsaußen abzugrenzen der wird eisern
durchgehalten wörtlich ich glaube dass
ihn aber verschenke manche in den
ostdeutschen Landesverbänden anders na
ja gut die Frage ist ja immer was ist
mit Rechtsaußen gemeint also ähm
das ist ja kommt ja jeden nachdem in
welchem Fernsehstudio sie sind und mit
welchen Journalisten sie sprechen da ist
ja die Auffassung sehr sehr
unterschiedlich also für uns ist klar
Rechtsaußen sind natürlich jene die sich
außerhalb unserer Verfassung bewegen ja
das schließt aber nicht aus dass wir
durchaus unsere konservativen Werte die
wir schon immer hatten natürlich auch
leben und nach vorne tragen solange
Verfassung für die ist wenn sie sich
abgrenzen von der Partei die AFD hat in
Teilen natürlich rechtsextreme Kräfte
ohne Frage und das ist auch der Punkt
weswegen eine Zusammenarbeit mit denen
für uns als völlig ausgeschlossen wird
Parteifreunden und Freunde sehen das
anders die sehen sogar bei den
Landtagswahlen nächstes Jahr in Sachsen
und Thüringen durchaus die Möglichkeit
für ein Bündnis eher als zum Beispiel
mit den Grünen das sind natürlich die
Diskussionen die Sie in einer großen
Volkspartei immer haben die haben sie
auch in anderen Parteien das ist an sich
nichts Ungewöhnliches man muss aber dann
diese Diskussionen führen man muss diese
Debatten führen und man muss vor allen
Dingen auch in diesen Debatten
innerparteilich überzeugen also gegen
eine Koalition oder ein Bündnis oder ein
bildungsbündnis in den Ostdeutschland
eine ganz klare Beschlusslage auf
bundesparteiischer Ebene sowohl mit der
AFD als auch mit der Linkspartei nichts
gemeinsam zu machen diesen Beschluss
haben wir gemeinschaftlich getroffen und
den ziehen wir auch so durch
selbstverständlich gleichwohl muss man
natürlich anerkennen gibt es gerade in
den neuen Bundesländern Themen Debatten
Probleme die wir als Partei ernst nehmen
müssen wir müssen unsere Leute dort
abholen und vor allen Dingen auch die
Bürgerinnen und Bürger und das ist das
eigentlich schwierige ja Abgrenzung
gegen Rechtsaußen gibt es da weil in den
westlichen Landesverbänden das
sicherlich anders diskutiert wird ist
die CDU in dieser Frage also der
Abgrenzung zur AFD ist die da in einem
Ost-West Dilemma naja wir haben
unterschiedliche politische Situationen
wenn ich in Bremen oder wenn ich nach
Bremen schaue dann haben wir da eine
andere politische Lage als sie
beispielsweise in Brandenburg oder
Sachsen der Fall ist das muss man
anerkennen trotzdem gilt für uns ganz
klar mit der AFD genauso wie Jan das
stimmt es gerade gesagt hat Georgien
nicht operieren nicht mit dir und das
muss ganz klar sein und ich muss ja auch
gerade mal etwas klarstellen noch mal zu
der werteunion und zu Herrn Maßen also
zu allererst ist es so dass wir
demokratisch aufgestellt sind und
deswegen kann weder Herr Laschet noch
her März beeinflussen wer in Thüringen
aufgestellt wird als
Bundestagskandidat ich glaube da waren
auch nicht alle glücklich mit und Tomate
Union ist kein offizielles Organ der CDU
das ist ein eigenständiger Verein da
kann jeder Mitglied werden das möchte
ich vermute sogar dass viele der
Mitglieder wir wissen es natürlich nicht
aber auch mittlerweile gar nicht mehr
Mitglied der cdu/csu sind und deswegen
finde ich auch den Vorschlag den ja
gerade auch der Bundesvorsitzende der
Jungen Union gemacht hat Johannes Winkel
ein unvereinbarkeitsbeschluss mit der
werteunion zu fassen für äußerst richtig
und wir haben den ja auch als Junge
Union schon seit 2021 so bestehen gesagt
hat
unvereinbarkeitsbeschluss mit der
Wirtinnen muss jetzt auf jeden Fall auch
sein wird ja auch an diskutiert der
Generalsekretär ihrer Partei Vater das
Silvia Player die stellvertretende
Parteivorsitzende Hermann Gröhe und
andere sagen das muss auf jeden Fall
gemacht werden ist das jetzt vielleicht
sogar der erste Schritt bevor es zu
diesem Ausschlussverfahren kommt ich
glaube dass man das parallel machen muss
das Präsidium hat jetzt ja auch schon
ganz klar die Mitglieder der CDU
aufgefordert aus der werteunion
auszutreten und wir haben den
unvereinbarkeitsbeschluss jetzt schon
bei der Jungen Union man muss ja auch
ehrlich gesagt
sagen die werteunion hat innerhalb der
CDU überhaupt keine Präsenz und auch
überhaupt keine inhaltliche Bedeutung so
sondern wir haben wir haben sehr hohe
innerhalb der werteunion eine große
Präsenz hat weil die beiden
Parteivorsitzenden Werte Union jeweils
renommierte CDU-Politiker waren und das
große Problem
Frau Winter das werden sie doch
zugeschrieben dass ein Mann von der AFD
aufgestellt wird denn dann existierenden
parteivorsitzen gerade frische März der
uns davor verkündet hatte wir ziehen
einen klaren Schritt gegen Schritt
gegenüber rechtsradikal nicht in der
Lage war zu erkennen dass sowohl Herr
Otte da lief ein
parteiausschussverfahren aber dass die
Kombination die absehbarer Weise wieder
CDU Leute nämlich als nächsten
dem Augenblick an dass die dass der der
Unvereinbarkeit Beschluss unabdingbar
gewesen wäre schon vor einem Jahr hätte
jetzt ungeprobleme erspart denn
natürlich ist dermaßen jetzt mit einer
Union im Schilde der nach wie vor
erhebliche Teile der CDU Mitglieder
angehören und die als solche eine
autorunion werden das ist ein Problem
ich bin ganz sicher dass der
unvereinbarkeitsbeschluss kommt es ist
bloß das Problem dass Maßen jetzt mit
dieser Auszeichnung Politik machen kann
und das ist etwas was man sich hätte
darf ich noch kurz eine Sache das hat
einfach gerade schon angesprochen für
dich märz ist ja angetreten mit
sozusagen dem der Ankündigung die als
die zu halbieren er sagt das hätte jetzt
seit 2018 nicht mehr wiederholt er hat
ja jetzt im Prinzip auch wahrscheinlich
dieses Ziel ausgegeben dass es eben
nicht Justin absehbarer Zeit ist es auch
eine realistische Einschätzung ja
absolut er hat ja sogar zurückgenommen
er hat gesagt die AFD und das Umfeld
haben sich so weit radikalisiert dass
der Teile für die CDU gar nicht mehr zu
erreichen sind also das ist ganz klar
dass das nicht funktionieren wird ich
wollte nur eine Sache sagen weil sie
gerade gesagt haben Herr Laschet hatte
da keinen direkten Zugriff das stimmt
natürlich weil die Kreisverbände die
Direktkandidaten aufstellen aber er
hätte sich natürlich mich dazu äußern
können und er hat gesagt und Wolfgang
Schäuble in dem Zusammenhang auch dass
Herr Maaßen durchaus einen Platz in der
in der CDU hat als Volkspartei also von
daher hat er das schon unterstützt auf
eine gewisse Art und Weise auch wenn es
eher wenn er es wahrscheinlich keine
gute Idee fand
beim Thema Migration hatten wir auch
schon kurz angesprochen das bleibt ja in
der Union nach wie vor umstritten da
gibt es dafür auch zwei Indizien einmal
die 20 Enthaltungen im Bundestag bei der
Abstimmung über das sogenannte
Aufenthaltsgesetz da ging es darum von
der Ampel eingebracht dass gut
integrierte geduldete auch bleiben
können also einen Daueraufenthalt
bekommen da gab es
20 Enthaltungen glaube ich aus der
Fraktion der cdu/csu im Bundestag sie
hatten in der letzten Woche auch noch
ähm eine Fraktionssitzung zu diesem
Thema mit externen das ist auch kein
Ergebnis
ist das nach wie vor ein Thema mit dem
die Union nicht zu den richtigen Kompass
hat wofür sie sich da jetzt entscheidet
weil es ja ganz offensichtlich auch ganz
unterschiedliche Äußerungen und
Meinungen dazu nicht davon aus dass eine
Partei ein monolitischer Block ist ich
meine wir leben in einer Demokratie und
überhaupt von uns mit Fug und Recht
volksparte zu sein und das bildet sich
in gewisser Weise natürlich auch in
einer Fraktion ab die entscheidende
Frage ist nicht wie viel
unterschiedliche Meinungen es in unserem
Hause gibt sondern die entscheidende
Frage ist wie wird diese Gruppe geführt
ja wird Debatte zugelassen ja werden
abweichende Meinungen auch zugelassen
wird ein abweichendes Stimmverhalten
zugelassen und da kann ich Ihnen ganz
ehrlich sagen hat sich einiges geändert
ja und ich finde dass jeder in unserer
Fraktion in unserer parteifamilie der
ein anderes Meinungsbild in welcher Art
und Weise auch immer wie hat akzeptiert
wird ja und respektiert wird man sollte
nur immer fair und offen dann auch mit
seiner parteifamilie umgehen ja ich
glaube würde das ja eher so deuten dass
die 20 Unterschriften die doch sehr
offensiv nach außen getragen wurden in
Zeichen dafür sind dass sie sich nicht
mitgenommen fühlten
beim Thema
Migration der Parteivorsitzende der
gesagt wir brauchen ja Migration zwar
Arbeitsmigration das hat ja da zwei
Fragen formuliert wen brauchen wir und
wer braucht uns die zweite Frage bezieht
sich auf das asyl- und Flüchtlingsrecht
er hat gesagt wir brauchen jede Menge
Zuwanderung in den Arbeitsmarkt und auf
der anderen Seite aber auch wer sich
illegal aus auch hier aufhält muss das
Land wieder verlassen er hat im
Zusammenhang mit der Zuwanderung in den
Arbeitsmarkt sogar dafür gesprochen dass
es auch noch eine viel bessere
Willkommenskultur für diese Menschen
geben muss ist das ähm die die Linie die
die Union jetzt auch durchhalten will
und diese auch durchhalten kann es gibt
ja da auch in den anderen Parteien
durchaus unterschiedliche Meinung aus
meiner Sicht eine sehr wichtige und
differenzierte Auffassung natürlich
brauchen wir den die Zuwanderung von
Fachkräften die muss man aber natürlich
differenzieren von den Menschen die
herkommen auch zum Teil um Schutz zu
suchen wir haben gerade erlebt dass
viele Frauen und Kinder aus der Ukraine
gerade nach Deutschland kommen die wir
hier natürlich aufnehmen die wir hier
natürlich versorgen die aber ja
perspektivisch sogar irgendwann zurück
möchten in die Ukraine und deswegen gar
nicht langfristig in unserem
Arbeitsmarkt sein wollen das ist
zumindest die Haltung vieler
Ukrainerinnen und Ukraine die ich in
Bremen erlebe und gleichzeitig müssen
uns natürlich fragen wie viele wie viele
Menschen können wir hier tatsächlich
helfen es gibt ja diesen schönen Spruch
unser Herz ist weit unsere Möglichkeiten
sind endlich und wenn ich sehe wie in
Bremen teilweise dann Menschen in Zelten
untergebracht sind wo man kaum mehr
sagen kann mensch das ist jetzt wirklich
eine würdige Art und Weise diese
Menschen unterzubringen und es gibt
Menschen die haben vielleicht gar kein
Aufenthaltsrecht dann finde ich es auch
richtig sofern das möglich ist diese
Menschen zurückzuführen in ihre
Herkunftsländer denn wir müssen zum
Schluss schauen wie vielen Menschen
können wir tatsächlich helfen und ich
bin der Auffassung dass wir vor allen
Dingen den Menschen helfen sollen
sollten ist wirklich die ist wirklich
brauchen weil in ihrem Land Krieg ist
weil sie in ihrem Land nicht weiterleben
können da wird Luke die
Kommunalpolitiker aller Couleur schlagen
ja Alarm wegen der Migrationen Seite sei
ungeordnet liegt auch daran dass die
Europäische Union sich überhaupt nicht
einig ist ist das nicht auch
verständlich dass die Union versucht auf
diese Weise nämlich Arbeitsmigration ja
illegale Migration nein versucht dieses
Problem in den Griff zu kriegen ja
unbedingt das sehe ich auch gar nicht
als Widerspruch eines deutlich zu sagen
das hat Frau Winter schon so recht
gesagt wobei ich sagen muss wenn es
Menschen unwürdige Verhältnisse in der
Aufenthalt von Migranten gibt dann muss
man und das sind die ein Problem diese
schaffen das ist ein riesiges Problem
Überforderung ist kein Problem der
Ausweisung ist klar zu sagen das Problem
der Ausweisung beginnt natürlich da wenn
du illegale Aufenthaltsrecht hast wenn
du Kriminalität hast darauf verweist die
Union meines Erachtens auch zum Teil
durchaus zu Recht das will ich gar nicht
diskretieren das Problem von Friedrich
Merz besteht bloß immer darin
dass man genau bei ihm merkt wann der
wahre märz zum Ausdruck kommt und das
war sein großes Unglück sage ich mal so
das war den kleinen Paschas also absolut
aus dem Bauch des Friedrich Merz
gesprochen hat dass man genau weiß in
dem Augenblick kam ein absoluter Effekt
durchaus übrigens eine tendenziellen
Richtung gegen die multikulturelle
Gesellschaft wohin gegen Töne die er
angeschlagen hat er hat mich dezidiert
beim Wahl bei seiner Wahl gesagt zu
Überraschung viele ich will die
Sozialpolitik Stärken ich will für eine
liberale soziale Politik stehen das
natürlich völlig unterbelichtet
geblieben ist das heißt Friedrich Merz
ist noch immer der größte Gegner seiner
selbst gewesen der größte Gegner von
Friedrich Merz heißt Friedrich Merz er
kommt nämlich immer dann wieder vehement
aus der Hüfte wenn er alte perfekte
bedient das ist einerseits übrigens auch
gar nicht nur unsympathisch ich muss ihn
gestehen das was Friedrich Merz man kann
ja mal was positives auch sagen was er
geleistet hat seine Vitalisierung von
Olaf Scholz also die Polarisierung im
Bundestag die er als
Fraktionsvorsitzender geleistet hat also
ein Mann wie Scholz und wahrlich nicht
Ausdruck von Leidenschaftlichkeit und ja
zu gewissen emotionalen Ausbrüchen total
anders zu haben das spricht für eine des
Parlaments ich halte Friedrich Merz als
Fraktionsvorsitzender für nicht von
schlechter von welchen Eltern nicht von
da ist er ein ein agiler Akteur gewesen
übrigens auch durchaus konstruktiv er
hat auch nicht nur auf fundamentale
Position gesetzt aber seine Leistung als
Parteivorsitzender war genau dessen wo
er eigentlich gefordert gewesen wäre bei
der Reparatur des Ansehens der CDU und
auch seine eigenen Werte die ihr alle
als hoch scharfgelten hat ja keinerlei
Zustimmungswerte momentan 20 % halten
für einen geeigneten Kanzler die
irgendwie nur bewegen würden das zu
leisten nämlich die Korrektur seines
sehr scharfen Profils also das was er
sich vorgenommen hat ist in diesem Jahr
sehr auf der Strecke geblieben
obwohl ich März politisch gesehen den
Bundeskanzler künstlich ernährt hat den
Bundestag werden wir gleich noch mal
genauer besprechen aber wir reden ja
auch über ein Jahr im auf der Position
des CDU-Chefs da musste er erstmal
entscheidenhausen zusammen kehren eine
verlorene krachend verlorene Wahl deren
Ursache ausschließlich eigentlich in der
eigenen Partei oder beiden Parteien lag
Krach mit der CSU inbegriffen
kurzfristig oder in relativ kurzen
Abständen zwei Parteivorsitzende
verschlissen die zwölf Monate die er da
jetzt hinter sich hat wie sehr ist er
oder wie weit ist er dieser
Mammutaufgabe gewachsen ich würde ihnen
recht geben dass natürlich die
Ausgangslage echt schwierig war also das
war schon ein ziemlich harter Job den er
da anzugehen hatte aber ich finde er hat
sich sehr auf die Fraktion konzentriert
und er hat die Partei komplett
vernachlässigt und die
Aufbauarbeit also diese inhaltliche auf
Neuaufstellung der unten der Union oder
der CDU die ja dringend notwendig ist
die hat bisher nicht stattgefunden und
das ist ein großes das ist ein großes
Maschinen die Partei zentrale das
adenauerhaus ja nicht eingeschlafen mit
Friedrich Merz sondern man könnte ja
eher von kreativer Unruhe sprechen z.B
bei der Personalpolitik wie hat er das
wie hat er die
Fraktionsarbeit kommt gleich noch die
Parteiarbeit die hatte die angegangen
zunächst einmal darf ein Politiker und
auch ein Parteivorsitzender Mensch sein
um das vielleicht an der Stelle mal klar
zu stellen ich glaube nicht dass sie von
ihrer Ex lernen ja ja weil sie haben ja
auf der einen Seite finden sie es
charmant das ist Spitzenpolitiker gibt
die auch mal Tacheles reden und auf der
anderen Seite verteufeln sie ihn ja also
ich finde das sympathisch weil wir
natürlich auch als Abgeordnete verorten
Feedback kriegen von den Menschen und
ich muss sagen das signalisiert mir dann
auch immer wieder dass wir so verkehrt
nicht liegen ja auch wenn man natürlich
über Tonalität und was weiß ich immer
wieder ähm sprechen kann und dann muss
man natürlich auch schauen von woher
kommen wir eigentlich unsere Partei hat
sich ja auch verändert in den letzten
Jahren Jahrzehnten wenn man das so sagen
darf und jetzt die Erwartung zu
formulieren als Experte wohl wissend
dass man sowas gar nicht von heute auf
morgen tun kann und ist vielleicht auch
gar nicht sinnvoll ist und nicht gewollt
ist ja ein eine eine Partei komplett
umzukrempeln ja das ist ja auch nicht
ganz wahr ja und insofern muss man immer
auch schauen wo stehen wir eigentlich
wer sind wir und was wollen wir
eigentlich und die sind
Diskussionsprozess den haben wir doch
jetzt auch eine sehr lebendige Art und
Weise wir haben viele Akzente jetzt auch
schon setzen können im Deutschen
Bundestag und ich verstehe ehrlich
gesagt ihre an den Haaren herbeigezogene
Kritik nicht gut
würde gerne Frau Winter noch sagen es
wird immer wieder gesagt öffentlich März
sei auch aufgrund seines Alters auch
aufgrund der Tatsache dass er auch seine
Überzeugungen eher ein
übergangsvorsitzender
würden Sie dem zustimmen oder ist er
noch jemand der die Partei nicht nur
wieder aufrichten kann sondern auch neu
ausrichten kann und eine Zeit lang auf
diesem Weg auch noch begleitet also ich
sehe Friedrich Merz als ein wirklich
mehr als vitalen Politiker der Lust hat
der der wirklich ein Willen hat auch
diese Partei zu reformieren und zu
ändern hat gerade ein Grundsatzprogramm
angestoßen das ist ein riesiges Projekt
das erfordert wahnsinnig viel
Koordination wahnsinnig viel Freiheit
die er der Partei auch gibt weil wir uns
gerade überlegen wie wollen wir uns
aufstellen für die nächsten 20 Jahre das
ist kein kleiner Prozess das ist auch
kein Prozess den man innerhalb von zwei
Wochen hinbekommt sondern deswegen läuft
der auch deswegen zu sagen er
konzentriert sich irgendwie nur auf die
Fraktion es ist aus meiner Sicht
komplett falsch weil dieser Programm so
dieser Prozess ist so intensiv ich bin
selber in der Fachkommission
Nachhaltigkeit ich weiß wieder die
Debatten geführt werden und das alles
macht Friedrich Merz er ist jemand er
hört zu er möchte lernen er hatte Lust
auf Politik und ich finde es echt
beeindruckend wie er das macht ganz ganz
ich muss ganz kurz ergänzen mich nervt
das total ich meine ganz ehrlich wir
leben in einer Gesellschaft wo wir uns
gegenseitig verbieten über Geschlecht
über Alter über Herkunft und so weiter
zu sprechen und was tun
sie tun nein also dass man dass man
Menschen abstempelt aufgrund eben diese
Eigenschaften und was tun Sie sie tun
genau das sie tun genau das ja indem sie
sagen oh das ist ein Parteivorsitzender
der hat das Alter x und ist er denn
überhaupt dafür das ist totaler Unsinn
ich habe die die Berichterstattung über
mit Friedrich März da zusammengefahren
da habe ich selbst meine eigene Meinung
noch gar nicht geäußert ich habe es
zusammengefasst und gleichzeitig gesagt
dass es auch Kritik an seine innerlichen
Ausrichtung gibt und dann die Frage ist
natürlich
wie fest sitzt er im Sattel und wird er
sie sind jünger als Friedrich Merz wird
diese diese Neuausrichtung der Union
noch anführen zusammenfassen
wenn Frau Schimke und das hat mit Alters
Rassismus und was sie jetzt anspielen
oder falscher Identitätspolitik was
vielleicht eine Marotte ist da war gar
nicht die Rede von ich kann sogar
Gerechtigkeit für Friedrich Merz sagen
ich habe doch gerade versucht ich finde
ihn hoch vital ich finde ihn hoch ich
finde ihn hoch vital sag ich deutlich
ich habe ihn gelobt als ja ganz jetzt
schreiben Sie so ich habe ihn gelobt ich
würde sogar sagen er hat zu
Revitalisierung von Olaf Scholz
beigetragen eine große Leistung und da
haben tatsächlich das hat die
Altersfrage spielt überhaupt keine Rolle
ich empfinde Friedrich mer ich sag sogar
ausdrücklich ich finde es sogar
ausdrücklich ich finde was sind 30 %.
wir liegen bei 30 %.
außerdem reden das ist auch schwierig
ich sage das Bedar darüber könnte man
viel länger reden was die CDU überhaupt
noch schaffen kann die CDU darüber lässt
sich sehr es liegt aber dummerweise auch
ein Faktor und der wird entscheidend
nicht ohne erheblich sein dass seine
eigenen Wert und darum geht's doch nur
wir sind doch hier fast Politik beraten
tätigen wir machen doch keine keine
Politik gegen Friedrich Merz es ist doch
eine große diskretanz vor dem
Hintergrund auch dieser 30 % der
Zuschuss werden von Friedrich Schmerz
persönlich und darüber wird er sehr viel
nachdenken und ich sage Ihnen eins die
Frage des Übergangs ist doch ganz
einfach die Frage des
übergangsvorsitzenden klärt sich
spätestens in zwei Jahren dann wird sich
nicht in zwei Jahren in zwei Jahren in
zwei Jahren aber wir wissen aber auch
warum Frau Merkel letztlich kanzlerinnen
wurde
einer mehr aufgrund einer explos von er
mehr aufgrund von einer Explosion von
Gerhard Schröder wahrscheinlich weil
ansonsten vielleicht Herr Koch und
andere sie weggeräumt so damit ich nur
sagen ich will doch nur folgen
jetzt kommt der letzte Punkt dass der
entscheidende nämlich sie werden in zwei
Jahren über die Frage des
kanzlerkandidats zu entscheiden haben
und wenn dann spätestens die Frage fällt
und die entscheiden darüber fällt ob
Friedrich Merz der geeignet ist und nur
darum geht es heute Abend die Frage
nämlich zu eruieren hat er das und kann
er bisher daraufhin gewirkt haben dass
er stärker geworden ist wenn es ihm
gelingt in zwei Jahren und natürlich
will er ist
verstehst dreimal angetreten das ist
eine Leistung er wollte nicht nur
Kanzler wenn es dreimal muss man
wirklich diesen äh sag mal ganz weit
Politiker animal März so gut halten ist
dreimal um den parteivors angetreten das
finde ich auch wirklich Leistung es
zeigt auch die Leidenschaft für die
Partei das sei deutlich gesagt er ist ja
er musste
automatisch ganze ich mache es vier
Jahre aus einer operationsrolle aber
wenn er in zwei Jahren nicht die
Kanzlerin Kandidatur bekommt und sie
nicht gerade einen Söder geht woraufhin
er noch parteiensvorsitzender CDU
bleiben könnte wäre es natürlich ganz
klar mit einer Kanzlerkandidatur eines
anderen
verbleibenden in den verbleibenden 17
Minuten langsam an die Frage
kanzlerkandiduran Robben deswegen würde
ich noch mal ein Stück gerne zurückgehen
Frau am Orte ist ja ein erfolgreicher
Oppositionspolitiker man hat ja von
einem auch Führer der Opposition da hat
man ja eine bestimmte Vorstellung
erfüllt er diese Erwartungen die ja
quasi auch verfassungsmäßig irgendwie
verankert ist er muss ja jederzeit in
der Lage sein auch die Regierung mit
seiner Partei abzulösen naja ich würde
da würde ich einfach von Luke Recht
geben dass er ihm als Oppositionsführer
im Bundestag erstmal eine gute Figur
macht also äh die Diskussionen haben
wirklich gewonnen das ist erstmal
positiv zu vermerken ob die CDU so
aufgestellt ist dass sie jetzt ad hoc in
die Regierung gehen könnte da würde ich
mal ein großes Fragezeichen hinterher
machen weil er in vielen Bereichen
einfach nur Orientierung fehlt und was
er dazu kommt ist dass dadurch dass er
März Parteichef ist und
fraktionsvorsitzender
im Grunde ganz viel auf ihn
zugeschnitten ist und nicht viel andere
Leute wirklich Strahlen können das hat
jetzt mal am Anfang gesagt und manche
probieren es auch aber es ist sehr
schwierig er hat ja selbst gesagt in
schwieriger Lage ist die Opposition hat
auch die Aufgabe der Regierung zu helfen
Stichwort Krieg gegen die Ukraine hat er
diesen Anspruch erfüllen können auch wie
er jetzt in den auch gerade in den
letzten Wochen die Diskussion auch um
Waffenlieferungen um die Aufstellung
Deutschlands in die Aufstellung des
Westens gegen Russland da mitzutragen
Hilfe ist vielleicht ein großes Wort
weil er natürlich der Regierung ist auch
schwer macht aber gut es ist als
Oppositionsführer seine Aufgabe und
er hat natürlich es einfach weil die Amt
weil die Ampel da ja so uneins ist also
er kann ja die Ampel vor sich her
treiben indem er sich positiv auf Frau
Zimmermann vor der FDP bezieht also das
sind ja immer wieder stallvorlagen die
da kommen und es kann ja gut umsetzen
und von daher finde ich das macht er
schon gut und bei manchen Aufgaben oder
manchen Entscheidungen sondern Vermögen
Bundeswehr zum Beispiel da hat er das da
finde ich da der das gut gemacht diese
Mischung aus sie setzen ihr eigenen
Interessen probieren die durchzusetzen
und verhalten sich aber gleichzeitig
gleichzeitig staatstragend das muss man
schon anerkennzahlen wenn man Friedrich
Merz und seine Politik jetzt noch mal
anzieht Frau Winter vor allem die Teile
der politischen Inhalte der Union die
sich auf die Zukunft beziehen also ihr
Bereiche sie sind in der klimaanion
aktiv da gibt es ja sicherlich auch
Kritik an der bisherigen Linie der Union
da muss ich vieles ändern der Vorsitz
der klimaion Thomas Heilmann hat gesagt
im Prinzip müssen wir die gesamte
Energie neu strukturieren neu erfinden
völlig neue aufstellen oder sogar mit
dem Wiederaufbau nach dem Krieg
verglichen zu sagen um Wohlstand für
alle zu sichern braucht es eine völlig
neue Klima und Energiepolitik die weit
weg ist von dem was wofür die Union
bisher stand wie sehen sie da die
Entwicklung ihrer Partei auch die Rolle
des Parteivorsitzenden gerade in dieser
Frage
wir sehen ja dass der Klimaschutz auch
in den Mittelpunkt der Beratungen
innerhalb der CDU kommt das haben wir
gerade sie haben es angesprochen unsere
letzte Klausurtagung in Weimar wo wir
ganz dezidiert mit Experten und Experten
auch über das Thema Klimaschutz unter
anderem mit Frau buezius aus Bremerhaven
vom Alfred Wegner Institut darüber
gesprochen haben und wir haben da eine
ganz klare Linie als Partei wir stehen
hinter dem Pariser Klimaabkommen wir
stehen hinter dem 1,5 Grad Ziel und wir
haben eine riesige Aufgabe für uns die
für meine Generation die entscheidende
Frage sein wird werden wir es schaffen
oder nicht werden wir es schaffen
weltweit das 1,5° C einzuhalten und ich
bin davon überzeugt dass die CDU die
richtige klimaschutzpartei ist warum
weil wir die Partei der sozialen
Marktwirtschaft sind und es nur mit der
sozialen Marktwirtschaft gelingen wird
die erneuerbaren Energien in dem Maße
auszubauen indem wir jetzt den Ausbau
brauchen und auf diesem Weg befinden das
heißt sie sind gegen die staatliche
Regulierung wofür möglicherweise andere
Parteien in der Klimaschutz und
Energiepolitik stehen sondern für
Marktwirtschaft oder gut dann frage ich
jetzt noch mal also
wenn ich fragen darf den Eindruck dass
die SPD eine Klimapolitik ohne soziale
Marktwirtschaft betreiben wollte ist
doch alles entschuldigen Sie bitte eine
Blase ich meine natürlich wird die Union
jetzt händeringend an das große
Weltklima Klimaschutz versuchen
Anschluss wenn Wolfgang sträuble war
dabei ehrlicher der sagte nämlich
dass wir damals den großen ersten
klimapolitiker der in unserer Fraktion
saß verloren haben der nämlich austrat
und dann zu den Grünen überzutreten das
war eine historisches scheitern an der
Klimapolitik und damit will ich sagen
das ist doch jetzt nicht plausibel dass
sie behaupten dass die Union dieses
Thema ernsthaft besetzen könnte in einer
originären Weise erklären Sie uns mal
Wolfgang Schäuble das sieht Wolfgang
Schäuble das sieht Wolfgang
jetzt versuchen eines Mannes der
wirklich sehr gut gemeint und ist dann
offensichtlich ich kann ja nur Wolfgang
Schäuble beim Wort nehmen
der eben tatsächlich sagte wir hatten
das muss ja die CDU müsste als
konservative Partei ein weit größeres
Interesse an Umweltschutz haben als sie
es je hatte das ist aber bloß mit dem
Befehl der sozialen Marktwirtschaft doch
nicht mal haben sie deswegen frage ich
haben Sie den Eindruck dass die FDP die
jetzt gerade hier ziemlich fatalerweise
die Politik der Ampel dominiert dass die
etwas anderes im Schilde führen würde
als eine Klimapolitik mit sozialer
Marketing gewesen erklären
was der Unterschied zu sein wollte
momentan macht an Politik ich finde es
erschreckend was da passiert und ich
finde übrigens auch erschreckend dass da
nicht noch ein größeres Medien Echo
kommt an dieser Stelle das
Klimaschutzgesetz was die Union mit
verabschiedet hat das wird jetzt von
Volker Wissing mit Füßen getreten der
legt ein Klimaschutz Sofortprogramm vor
wo wo wo ein Expertenrat der Regierung
selber sagt wir können es nicht mal
bewerten so schlecht es ist schauen wir
mal weiter schauen wir auf europäische
Ebene wo Peter Liese ein CDU Mann gerade
durchgesetzt hat dass der
Emissionshandel deutlich erweitert wird
ein so wichtiges Thema weil wir damit
die Emissionen insgesamt begrenzen wer
war dagegen wer hat dagegen gesprochen
die Sozialdemokraten und die Grünen im
Europäischen Parlament ist die CDU als
eine Übersicht hinbringen wie ist die
CDU als eine offene Klimaschutzpolitik
im Verkehrsbereich bisher noch nicht
aufgefallen haben sie das Tempo 130 oder
100 in ihrem Report war also ich meine
ich finde das Rühren ich finde das
wirklich
auf 100 Fragen zum Klimaschutz ist ein
bisschen Ansprache
der Unterschied der Unterschied zwischen
uns und anderen politischen Mitbewerbern
liegt doch darin dass wir einen
Klimaschutz und eine Klimaschutzpolitik
betreiben die erstens den gesunden
Menschenverstand widerspiegelt das heißt
natürlich den Weiterbetrieb von
Atomkraftwerken beispielsweise auch zu
fordern Punkt 1 und Punkt 2 dass wir
natürlich auch die ausreichenden
marktwirtschaftlichen Mechanismen mit
drin haben wir machen sozusagen keine
Planwirtschaft wo wir den Menschen etwas
überhelfen ja was am Ende nicht gelebt
wird und was nicht praktisch ist
haben eine
planwirtschaftsminister musste man ja
quasi zu seinem Glück zwingen bisher
irgendwann mal Begriff das ist
vielleicht doch sinnvoll ist Atomkraft
weiter zu betreiben
endet dann jetzt zwar irgendwann aber
das war ein Beschluss der von der
geschätzten Bundeskanzlerin Angela
Merkel mit Mehrheit durchgesetzt hat gar
nichts zu tun im Raum die Fokussierung
auf ausschließlich auch E-Mobilität ob
das uns wirklich weiterhelfen wir sind
die Partei wir sind die Partei die
technologieoffenheit fordert
diesen doch eine wir wollten ja über
Inhalte der unionen nicht nur zur
Klimaschutzpolitik Frau und aber Orte
ein Thema oder wichtige Themen sind
Demografie Stichwort
Fachkräftemangel aber auch Rentenpolitik
Familien und Frauenpolitik wie sieht es
da aus was kann die was kann der was
können die Wählerinnen und Wähler davon
der CDU erwarten es geht bei der
Bundestagswahl sind ja nicht nur die
Anhänger von Friedrich Merz
wahlberechtigt sondern eine große breite
Bevölkerung die
möglicherweise da auch noch ganz andere
Ansichten hat und die Union möchte ja so
schnell so schnell wie möglich wieder
Kanzlerpartei werden was muss sie da in
diesen Bereichen Demokratie Familien
Frauenpolitik tun naja beim beim Thema
Rente zum Beispiel ist es so dass
arbeiten Sie noch einen Konzept da weiß
man nicht so genau was kommen wird
das ist lange liegen geblieben und
da muss man tatsächlich hingucken da
soweit ich weiß sitzt da gerade Carsten
Linnemann dran und äh er arbeitet ein
Konzept das muss man abwarten beim
Fachkräftemangel ist es schon so dass
Sie dass die CDU natürlich auch der
Ansicht ist dass es Einwanderung geben
muss aber es gibt keine richtigen
Konzepte dafür das ist in vielen Fällen
einfach so dass das die inhaltliche
Untermauerung noch fehlt deshalb sagte
ich ja vorhin auch dass ich nicht glaube
dass sie jetzt flugs in die Regierung
springen könnte wenn oder das eine gute
Idee wäre wenn es so kommen würde
beim Fachkräftemangel finde ich auch das
tatsächlich da könnte man noch mal zu
dieser Äußerung mit den kleinen Paschas
auch wenn ich das nicht überstrapazieren
will kommen dass
die Frage ist ob man der Union dieses
nach solchen Äußerungen die
dieses reden von Willkommenskultur
abnehmen kann und das glaube ich ist ein
großes Manko also das ist jetzt auch
unten das ist jetzt wirklich erfunden
weil diese Aussagen
also dass ihr ihre Schlussfolgerung die
sie jetzt
Kombination diese die sie sozusagen hier
treffen das eine hat mit dem anderen
überhaupt nichts zu tun überhaupt nicht
das die Bemerkung von Friedrich Merz
bezog sich auf Integrationsprobleme von
hier lebenden Migranten wie auch immer
ob das Deutsche sind oder ob das
geflüchtete sind völlig egal haben wir
auch das die Sendung
Masala saß
anerkannter Militärexperte
mit dem italienischen Vater der der
gesagt hat ihr spuckt uns ins Gesicht
der so empört war über diese aus
Äußerung und wenn Sie das ich glaube
dass sie solche Äußerung mal ernst
nehmen müssen wenn sie diese wählen
können das Thema Fachkräftemangel
angesprochen haben
sie ja von Mindestlohn nicht so viel
aber ist nicht ein Problem des
Fachkräftemangel auch die dass man
einfach die Leute zum Beispiel der
Gastronomie einfach besser bezahlt dass
er das da also jetzt als ein Beispiel
das auch daran liegt dass es auch in den
ökonomische Ursachen an der
sozialpolitische hat also das wurde ja
dann bedeuten wenn wir in der Gastro
einen Finanz- oder ein ein bezahlproblem
hätten dann wären ja wahrscheinlich die
dort fehlenden Menschen an anderer
Stelle ausreichend vorhanden was nicht
der Fall ist nein wir haben und das ist
der Grund warum wir jetzt auch was die
Fachkräfte Einwanderung betrifft immer
wieder sagen naja es gibt doch Gesetze
wir sind der Auffassung dass die
Gesetzeslage die wir haben das was wir
in der letzten Koalition beschlossen
haben dass das an sich gut und richtig
ist woran es aber fehlt ist die ganze
Infrastruktur drumherum wer beschließt
das wer bearbeitet die Anträge sind die
imstande die ganzen Anträge zu als kann
doch nicht sein dass man eine
dreiviertel Jahr im Ausland wartet bis
man bei der Botschaft mal einen Termin
bekommt und die ganz wichtige Frage wer
will denn eigentlich noch nach
Deutschland kommen sind wir noch
konkurrenzfähig Steuern und Abgaben ja
kann man vielleicht auch in anderen
Ländern
da ist eine große
Erklärungsbedürftigkeit der cduismus auf
der anderen Parteien direkt laminieren
die Schwäche eine Staates der Geld
kosten wird der sehr viel Geld kosten
würde übrigens auch in der Frage der
Rüstung spannende Frage wenn die CDU in
Sachen Rüstung immer weiter vorbricht
das ist ein ziemlich heikler Punkt das
wird sie auch noch wahrscheinlich
reflektieren nach den Leopard Panzern
kam seitens der Union sind sofort die
nächste Forderung wir gehen da auch
weiter ob es Kampfjet anderes hin das
kostet alles Geld wir werden sehr viel
Geld möglicherweise ja und sie wollen
das sie wollen das Geld finanzieren auf
die aufgrund der Tatsache dass wir
Steuern senken und dass wir Steuern
senken den Stahl verschlagen das ist
eine ganz spannende Frage ich bin sehr
gespannt wie die CDU oder eine plausible
Antwort drauf sind die plausible Antwort
ist die dass wenn sie Steuern senken sie
Anreize für Arbeit setzen und am Ende
das Geld dann durch den Konsum etc
wieder eingegangen
hatte bekanntlich weit höhere Steuern in
Zeiten die weit haben Frau Schimke und
wir werden noch erleben dass wir eine
große Debatte darüber dass der Beamten
geführt und viele andere dass dieser
starken durch viele verschiedene ich
würde gerne noch auf die Arbeits- und
Sozialpolitik aber wichtig wir sind ja
bei dem Thema schon vor Winter
in Bremen das Thema Arbeits- und sozial
ist in der in ihrer Heimatstadt ein ganz
wichtiges Thema
sind denn es gibt ja eine starke
Strömung der CDU traditionell die
christliche demokratische
Arbeitnehmerschaft von dem man das
Gefühl hat sie ist aber im Moment taucht
nicht so richtig auf eine Diskussion wie
muss ihre Partei gerade mit diesem mit
diesem Inhalten umgehen also für uns in
Bremen ist das natürlich ein großes
Thema weil wir sehr viele Menschen in
Bremen haben die von Armut betroffen
sind fast die Hälfte der Kinder in
Bremen lebt in Armut wir haben ein
großes Bildungsproblem was das ganze
noch weiter verschärft und deswegen
setzen wir uns intensiv mit diesem Thema
auseinander gerade auch in Bremen und
ich erlebe auch ganz häufig ein wirklich
sehr leidenschaftlichen Glauben an der
das Thema immer wieder auf die
Tagesordnung hebt und auch gerade wenn
man den letzten Bundestag ist der von
NRW der der
Minister
wir haben
wir haben gerade auf dem letzten
Bundesparteitag eine Diskussion erlebt
die insbesondere von der CDA geführt
wurde von daher würde ich sagen dieser
Teil der CDU ist auf jeden Fall aktiv
und auch macht selbst auch seine Punkte
und hat ja auch recht das ist ein Thema
was viele Menschen beschäftigt
jedenfalls war ja das oder das wirklich
märz bei dem Thema tarifreue das wurde
ja gefordert von der CDA auf dem
arbeitgeber-tag gesagt hat dass er nur
ein kleiner Teil unserer Partei der das
fordert also mehr
Treue den Tarifverträgen gegenüber das
wurde so interpretiert dass die CDA
keine große Rolle mehr spielt in der CDU
ich glaube das in der CDU in einer
Volkspartei jede Stimme eine Rolle
spielt und dass die auch ernst genommen
wird natürlich müssen wir schauen wo
sind zum Schluss die Mehrheiten
innerhalb der CDU und da gibt es eine
CDA da gibt es aber auch eine miet und
da gibt's natürlich Diskussion und das
ist ja auch Demokratie das ist ja das
was eine Partei auch gesund und lebendig
macht
dass da so betont hat war schon eine
kleine dimitierung der CDA muss man
sagen
und widersprach genau seine Anspruch das
soziale nach vorne zurück und dass sie
wieder Herrn Laumann bringen müssen ist
rührend geht das seit 20 Jahren
verkörpert seitdem Herr Blüm nicht mehr
quasi die vor der Vorbrecher ist ist ein
auffälliges Symptom dafür dass die Union
in der sozialen Frage nicht den Reichen
vorkommt das kommt immer auf Maß und
Mitte an sowohl die CDA hat gute
Vorschläge als auch wir als
mittelstandsunion beispielsweise und es
ist natürlich bei einem Parteitag ist es
immer ein Ringen um den richtigen Weg
und manchmal hilft auch ein Mittelweg ja
und insofern haben sich die Delegierten
mehrheitlich damals dagegen entschieden
diesen Antrag in der Form durchzubringen
und wir diskutieren das natürlich jetzt
in aller Ruhe aus ich habe ja gesagt wir
reden noch mal ganz kurz über die
Kanzlerkandidatur dazu noch zwei Dinge
die ja auch hier schon angesprochen
worden ist einmal dass die Union ja
eigentlich Umfragen sehr gut da steht
irgendwo riesen Abstand hat gegenüber
der nächsten Partei jeweils in der grüne
oder ist mir die von 10%, dass diese
dass die persönlichen Werte von
Friedrich Merz aber nicht so gut sind
was bedeutet das denn eigentlich auch
für diese Frage dass die CDU ja nicht
mehr allzu lange an dieser Diskussion
er führt uns in den Bundestagswahlkampf
2025 vorbeikommt na sie wird alles sie
wird alles tun um den Ball flach zu
halten in dieser Frage weil es natürlich
eine sehr konfliktreicher Punkt ist also
ich glaube dass das bis zur Wahl in
Bayern im Oktober erst mal ruhig ist
weil Herr Söder auch kein Interesse
daran hat das Thema zu bespielen dass
danach aber sollte die Bayernwahl für
die CSU gut aussehen ist natürlich
wieder die Frage ist will er nicht doch
diesen sprungwagen und wäre er nicht der
der bessere Kandidat weil er bessere
beliebtheitswert hat ich glaube dass das
für ein märz und wirklich großes Problem
ist dass er von diesem Image er ist er
steht aus diesen alten Mustern heraus
neoliberal soziale Kälte er wirkt
arrogant das sind ja immer die Sachen
die geäußert werden wenn man über ihn
spricht und er hat diese
Beliebtheitswerte Politbarometer ähm
immer nur Sarah Wagenknecht und Alice
schneiden schlechte ab das musste
natürlich zu denken geben
wird er kanzlerkandidatinnen egal was
solche Umfragen sagen ich muss mich als
CDU-Mitglied repräsentiert fühlen durch
meinen Parteivorsitzenden und späteren
Kanzlerkandidaten und das tue ich sehr
gut und insofern
nicht nur die Frage nicht nur die Frage
wer tritt am Ende an wer hält den Kopf
hin sondern vor allem auch folgt ihm die
Partei so und da mache ich mir ehrlich
gesagt keine Sorgen und dann machen wir
auch den Punkt heute
beobachten das auch weiter bedanke mich
bei Jana Schimke bei Winter besser die
Sabine am Orte und bei Albrecht von
Lucke Liebe ZuschauerInnen liebe
Zuschauer morgen in der Phönix Runde
Diskussion um Kampfjets wie weit geht
der Westen
aktuelles auch in Phoenix Tag darin noch
mal in voller Länge das Interview mit
Hans-Georg Maaßen bleiben Sie bei uns
[Musik]